[Music]
I'm the one
we'll figure it out by the end of the
show yeah I think we'll figure it out
all right so special podcast today we
were hoping to do it in March but we
couldn't but we're able to make it work
today and uh a lot of people online with
the pack you got you got to get them on
Pat you got to get them on here they'd
be great be a great conversation finally
we made it make it work newly a father
of seven months which is congratulations
to you thank you it's great to have
David Pacman on the podcast it's so
great to be here I'm shocked people
wanted me here they really did that I
mean you were getting tagged left and
right get this guys I love you we're
talking on the Twitter and yeah anyways
we were able to make your work so how
how's everything how you doing
everything's good good yeah how's it
feel being a father it's it's weird it's
like completely different and kind of
everything's the same you know it's
weird and biggest shock I mean yeah like
oh I didn't expect this
um you know I thought maybe like two or
three diapers would be enough for a few
months you need way more than two or
three rookie so what's most expensive
cost that you're feeling well the most
expensive one was the night nurses at
the beginning because as you know my
audience knows my girlfriend ended up
back in the hospital after the delivery
and it was me at two weeks and and so I
was like we need night nurses and night
nurses you know are not the cheapest
thing wow so that was the so after that
I'm like oh diapers this is this is
great diapers is cheap yeah night nurses
yeah that's pretty epic I'll wait till
uh they turn one and you find out how
much eggs are gonna cost it's gonna be
catastrophic so hang in there it's
coming well she's already on eggs you
know so it's uh yeah by the way public
PSA I'm also looking for some night
nurses out there I don't have any kids
but if some night nurses just want to
come
you're looking for a night you want to
come in and take care of some things
throughout the night just his
interpretation of night nurses are very
different than David David is not in the
adult entertainment business David is
not like in you know a player he's just
saying somebody that was helping him
with yeah these are medical
professionals exactly that's a better
way of putting that's all I'm looking
for as well here gentlemen it's a mouth
to mouth all right stop it let's go okay
so David for the people that don't know
if you can take a quick moment and just
kind of give them your background you've
got a massive YouTube channel your you
got billions of views online you've done
great work you and then maybe share with
them what your philosophies are what you
believe in and we'll get started so my
30-second backstory born in Argentina
family moved to the U.S immigrant
learned the language Public School
etc etc all of that different stuff
interested in media interested in
politics and Argentina politics is like
everything everybody's always talking
about politics I'm sure you know in your
background it's similar
um and eventually started this community
Radio Show podcast when I was a do an
undergrad
had the fortune that I could just kind
of try making it a job while a lot of my
you know classmates ended up having to
get real jobs that were not very good
um and it it worked fortunately I think
it was a combination of timing and the
opportunity and the fact that I had a
situation where I could just let's see
if this thing works and I can avoid
having to get a real job
um and then it combined with when
YouTube was blowing up and podcasting
and all these things so my show is a
it's a left-wing Progressive call it you
know whatever you want sort of podcast
and I'm sure we'll get into my
philosophy more specifically
um but we are we that's the space I
occupy and we talk news and politics do
interviews I've done over 1500
interviews on the show
um and that's that's the thing now we're
multi-platform YouTube Facebook twitch
podcasts Etc so look my biggest
challenge with you is I think you go a
little overboard when it comes on to
supporting Trump and I think it's
inappropriate I know yeah honestly like
it's a little too much I know people who
are Mega people they love him
I just think his hair and his physical
uh prowess and strength is so incredible
his golf game is unbelievable and I
consider golf a proxy towards basically
everything in life if you're a good
golfer the way Trump is yeah then you're
good at everything really I mean that's
that's the best but by the way do you
miss him be honest do I miss him so that
there's a and a crazy question for you
just a crazy question for you like for
me you know how uh CNN ratings just came
out and ratings you know I don't know
what the numbers was we'll get into it
here in a minute uh worse in nine years
I don't know what the numbers were but
if you can pull up the article worse
than nine years right so do you think
like
you sit there and you say like for
comedy yeah like comedians
you know a great comedian maybe can do
make fun of everybody yeah okay Schultz
he can do anybody Chappelle can do
anybody Rogan these guys can't do
anybody right you know but sometimes
like the market needs a good president
to make fun of yeah right so you know
there's a lot you can do with Biden but
there's a lot more you can do with oh
absolutely and he's he's so funny in
spite of himself yeah and sometimes it's
he'll say one thing like he'll call you
know the the CEO of Lockheed Maryland
Lockheed but that's not her name her
name's her last name is not the name of
the company that's funny in the moment
Tim Apple Tim apple right there's these
art I said Tim Cook you pretty much said
Tim Apple there's this Arc like for
example where Trump weirdly gets
obsessed with toilets during his during
his 2020 campaign I don't know if you
guys remember this but he would go to
rallies and he would go and they're
they're turning down the flow on my
toilets you're gonna have to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times and I'm thinking
what is Trump doing with a toilet where
you need 10 flushes right it's weird but
that's just the first piece so then on
Election night when he talks about how
he really won you know which he lost by
the way yeah um he he says what there
were massive dumps in the middle of the
night and you're like 15 flushes massive
dumps and then later for you later that
was good later you find out he was
flushing documents down the toilet so
you're like going back a year that's the
reason the toilet he was so concerned
about toilets he's flushing documents
himself so how do you handle the whole
uh uh you know but even for yourself as
a content creator do you miss him as a
kind like would you selfishly forget
about political of course you don't want
him you would have probably had Bernie
over Biden I would assume maybe somebody
else who would have been your guy if you
had your choice yeah I mean I I think
Bernie is the closest when you look at
policy to me but I've been very critical
of the way Bernie runs his campaign I
Bernie talks about he's a socialist I
don't know I'm not a socialist and I
don't actually think Bernie ran on a
socialist platform but we can get to
that interesting but I I've said to my
audience Trump was great for shows like
mine there's no question about it right
like speaking if I was if I was Voting
not for what I think is best for the
country but what's best for me
financially of course Trump was a gold
mine there's no question about it so who
who did you want like if you were to say
like today you have your choice on who
can be the president who would you like
it's the the reason I'm going to answer
the question but the reason that it's a
hard question to answer in that way is
there's policy and there's who could win
who would be good at governing who can
who understands how to make compromise
and sort of how politics is done so I
think there's a ton of really
interesting people that do well in all
of these areas and and I'll give you a
few names and I from this is now for my
audience because if what I'm about to
say they'll say you you're just the
insult in Myspace is you're a lib
meaning I'm not aggressive I'm not left
enough right okay I think folks like
it's it's crazy yeah I think the people
that are striking the right balance
right now between policy and rhetoric
and ability to actually be good
politicians are people like and this is
gonna be crazy okay Gavin Newsom Pete
bootage Stacy Abrams Katie Porter in
California I think these are really
interesting folks who I don't
necessarily agree with them on all
policy but I think they bring a few
things that are important they're
younger right now I think there's a
problem where it's it's sort of like old
guy after old guy after old guy on both
sides we're seeing this to a degree so I
like that I think they bring some
Progressive policies that are
interesting without really being
brandable as being socialists and I
think that that's all really important
right now for the for the left so what
do you like about so okay so let's let's
stay with who we currently have right
now so today Biden yeah what's he doing
good what do you think he's not doing
good okay so if I were to say here are
the things that Biden got done that are
accomplishments that are important and
you know think things that that are
worth doing at a time where I think it
was necessary he did that third coveted
stimulus remember Trump did two of them
and Biden Biden did a third one I think
at the time it made sense and he didn't
include as much of this or really any if
I recall the PPP slush fund which was so
fraudulently used and now you know the
IRS is backed up on audits in part
because they're doing PPP fraud
investigation so I like that he didn't
include that I didn't think that that
was necessary inflation reduction act
does a lot of interesting things and
whether or not it quote reduces is
inflation inflation is coming down now
several months in a row I love the
renewable energy stuff that's in there I
drive an electric car I've got the solar
panels I've got you know my gas stove
I'm even going to get rid of I'm ready
I'm ready to get rid of it I'm being
dead serious no yeah you're fully
committed it's not a commitment it's the
induction is unbelievable once you
actually learn to use it it's fantastic
I was repeating oh you get the gas stove
you can modulate down to it's beautiful
I've now cooked with induction it's
fantastic so I'm I'm fully I think it's
fantastic I think encouraging that we're
not Banning gas stoves of course I'm
exaggerating I think that that's really
great
um I think getting getting out of
Afghanistan I think was the absolute
right decision many criticisms of the
chaos that unfolded when Trump was asked
how would you have done it differently
he didn't actually have any answer it
was Trump's plan to get out that Biden
did a few months later because Trump
never got to it for whatever reason I
think that was the right decision it was
going nowhere 20 years there Etc
um on student loan forgiveness I don't
know what's going to happen eventually
I'm not a forgive all student loans guy
some in my audience are like David all
loans should be forgiven it's like no I
don't think so I don't think that makes
sense but we've had programs like if
you're a doctor and you work in an
underserved Community long enough you
qualify to get those loans forgiven I
think certain programs like that make a
lot of sense so I think that that's a
good thing and quite frankly and this is
where you know the the Trump people
email me and they get very mad if not my
opinion if we go by Gallup opinion
survey what other countries think of the
US opinion of the U.S has dramatically
improved since Biden replaced Trump I
think that matters I I'm not an
isolationist so I think it's important
that other countries respect the office
of the presidency and under trump it was
a joke you know literally laughed at at
the UN goes to India mispronounces 10
Indian names and the crowd is just
leaving it it was a humiliation
everywhere he went so I think that's a
great it's like a soft thing that I
think is really good so the the fact
that we're no longer feared is a good
thing I don't know where you're getting
that we are no longer fear so you think
people fear Biden what I'm asking you is
where what data do you have that we are
no longer well that's not it that's what
data is not uh any data to give I mean
how do you know what it is well no but
but during by during Biden is when
Russia felt comfortable bullying Ukraine
during Biden is uh even if you look at
Afghanistan on the way we left people on
the left we're not happy by the way we
left Afghanistan which even 82 billion I
can give you a lot of different names
like the CIA who's the CIA guy that we
had here who was on uh
with a z what's his name
um Matt Zeller Matt Zeller CI agent who
was on MSNBC he called him out he was on
MSNBC with uh but that's one person
right but there's a lot of them though
if I actually said if I actually pull it
up and if I if I do the Google search on
it I'll find plenty of names from their
own side let's do it that's fine but I
think one important thing to back up is
you first kind of gave me what's not
really a very fair question you go are
you not worried that the US is no longer
fear so you're saying they they don't
fear but hold on let me finish let me
finish my response so yeah you first
presented to me and these are a lot of
conversations go like this you present
to me is it not a concern to me that the
U.S is no longer feared and I said well
where are you getting that where's the
data you go out there is no data so
where let's first start with no what I
said is this that's not the fee I didn't
say there's no data you can't you can't
pull data meaning you can't find data on
fear and how do you know that that fear
is action fear is action did during uh
did during Trump Russia attack Ukraine
no that's not what happened with
Palestine and Israel
what happened yeah what happened they
came together after 20 some years what
what are you talking about when you say
what are you talking about
has there been any progress on peace
very limited did moving the cat did move
it wasn't the capital Did moving the
embassy Embassy let me ask the question
did moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem get us closer to peace or did
it get us further further away do either
of you guys know I don't know if you've
studied this issue there's arguments on
both end but it has not led to peace and
prosperity in Palestine correct did
Trump promise this this very critical
clear question did Trump promise that
Jared commissioner would solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict during the
first term yes nobody promise it I don't
know if he promised it or promises made
Promises Kept he was assigned to that
Duty and did it happen
what happened did Jared negotiate no but
I don't think anybody believed that
peace was happening so it's okay for him
to make promises
but make the make the argument go back
to the argument about the fact that
America on all polls today is would you
say liked what was the word you used so
I I think the really important thing
when we talk about this is we talk about
what we can measure so the Gallup
polling that has been done so you trust
polls oh come on but that's where we're
going though there are there are lots
because I trust certain polls too but
I'm saying so you trust polls if you say
do I trust a Rasmussen Republican
primary poll 18 months before an
election I would say that's a that's not
very valuable I don't think that's
valuable the Gallup public opinion
sentiment poll that has been done over
many many presidents in the same way I
think that that's a pretty good poll
just to give a sense of how the world
feels about the American president I
have no reason to distrust that there
are other polls where I would have a
specific reason to distrust but we're
kind of going like 10 10 tangents here I
think if we want to talk about
am I upset that the U.S isn't feared
since you brought that question forward
the appropriate thing would be for you
to give me the data but no go go back to
what you said you said us is what you
said you like the fact that U.S has
liked more today under Biden no I didn't
use that term what was the term you used
if you don't mind it again on average
yeah countries respect the us more now
that Biden is President you value that I
think it's important because I and I can
I tell you why sure I think it's
important because between trade and
globalization and problems we deal with
that don't respect the borders of
countries it's important to be again
it's not about liked it's not about it's
to be respected globally I do think that
that actually so so why do you think
they didn't like or respect Trump let's
see what you're gonna say with that why
do you think tell me the guy's a joke he
is yeah okay tell us why and bike man
Biden's not a joke well we can we can
talk about Bible because Biden's like
the
[Music]
but I think it's important to say are we
talking about Trump or are we talking
about Biden no no talk about identify I
talk about them one at a time stay on
Trump okay on Trump when he sees a joke
tell us why you think he's a joke
um
promises made that were not kept that he
told us he was going to achieve for us
let's look at some of them I'm going to
get rid of Obamacare and replace it with
his word a beautiful replacement where
everyone will have care and it's going
to be affordable okay
just flat out didn't happen the one
proposal that Republicans made would
have led to 24 to 32 million people
losing health care I consider that a
failure I don't think Obamacare is
perfect but it's better than the think
Trump think Trump said he was going to
bring us that was that was just a
failure two build a wall across the
entire U.S Mexico border which Mexico is
going to pay for
it's not even worth having a conver I
mean just a joke of course of course
completely didn't happen solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict no progress
made in fact to be honest and this is
you know if we want to delve into that
moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem got us further from that
because it's seen as a sort of
um a taunting measure if you understand
the internal politics of what's what's
going on there
um was going to you know the made some
space travel promises I mean we could I
can't think of promises he made that he
did keep other than
um I guess the the he was going to do
tax reform and he did tax reform so as a
policy matter a complete and total
failure I do think maybe the first step
act on Criminal Justice Reform did some
good things I'm I'm sort of glad to give
him credit on that
um but so you know on policy failure and
then you know on rhetoric we could spend
three hours just looking at quotes so
I'm curious to see exactly how you think
now yeah if if covet doesn't happen does
he get reelected yes why well because
his followers don't care about policy I
interview them all the time and I say
followers don't care about power they
don't care about achievements they care
about Hillary bad Hillary Marxist
Hillary socialist you think Hillary's
good
did I say that no I'm asking you oh no
uh I don't think Hillary was a good
candidate and she's she's to my right
um no I don't think Hillary's good but I
thought she was better than Trump she's
to your right she's to my right yeah
Hillary is a very moderate conservative
Democrat yeah your world yeah yeah good
I mean give me a left-wing Hillary
policy like a really left-wing Hillary
policy
you're saying you would much rather have
a Hillary than a trump I would rather
okay so go back much rather I don't know
so so go back to he gets reelected why
because his uh uh voters could care less
about policies that's what you're saying
fine no problem so but we both know that
it's not the right that's elected him
and it's not the left that'll like
whoever on the left it's whoever's in
the middle that's the a to 12 percent
that kind of says you know what I'm
gonna go this side you know this time
around or versus more people come out
for you know their candidate meaning a
lot of people would come out for Obama
okay so explain yourself what it
actually more depends on is who chooses
to go out and vote it's less about you
know there's there's often this idea in
politics and there's lots of people who
are really good on this issue that you
could talk to Rachel bidikoffer and even
Frank Luntz even though he's partisan I
think he would concede this as well he's
a poster yes the idea of the Swing
independent voter that sometimes on
unpreced elections will vote for a
Republican and sometimes a Democrat very
very small percentage of people more
common is that a candidate either
activates people to vote or those same
people just stay home in the U.S we have
an embarrassingly low voter voter
turnout it's between usually usually 52
and 60 percent I think so almost half
the electorate isn't even voting it's
less about people who vote one way and
then another way it's more about people
who say I'm just going to stay home
versus I'm going to go out and vote if
they vote it's clear so you're saying
that the middle voter doesn't matter at
all no I didn't say that so what are you
saying I said they matter much less than
who who is partisan chooses to vote but
it's fair to say that okay if if he
continues so if he continues
and there's no covid he would get
reelected do you think the let's
specifically Target the middle forget
the people on the side that would show
up well why that's that's the question I
want to do with you right now so if we
if we specifically focus on the middle
what the middle the independent the
Libertarians would they have chosen to
stick with Trump or would most have
wanted to replace him with somebody else
it's a polling question I don't know the
data well you're the poor guy so I'm
asking you I don't have the data in fact
okay I'd be curious to know so you're
but you're also correcting me to say
that's not true that's the middle and
the Independence that that didn't elect
them you're saying it's who showed up
that elected him as a general concept
right elections swing less based on
Independence who sometimes vote
Republican and Democrat that's a small
factor a bigger factor is are voters
activated by their candidate or are they
deactivated where they go I don't like
this person but I'm definitely not
voting for that one I'll stay home so
isn't it a bit of both though it's a bit
of both because
we've seen in countless stories about I
voted for Obama I'm not racist I voted
for Obama what are you talking about I
voted for Bush then I voted for Obama
and then Trump showed up he made some
promises he he was in the midwest he was
he was he was he was out there he was
reaching out touch your hands Hillary
was too busy in New Mexico and Arizona I
decided to vote for Trump and I was sort
of done with Trump now I'm back on Biden
yeah we see so many stories like that
that's what he's Independence that's an
anecdote and so I think anecdotes are
fine but one of the things that um is
important is to zoom out from anecdotes
and to look at the broader data and the
other thing that's important is a lot of
that cross-voting it cancels each other
out because you see roughly the same
amount from one side versus the other
and what what I mean by that is there
was if you look at the crossover in 2016
the number of Democrats who decided to
vote Trump in 2016 was very similar to
vote McCain in 2008 so it it's it's a
roughly predictable number you're
talking about Democrats who have
switched over just there's legitimate
Independence I'm giving you just one
example of this people who go either way
or whatever it's it's relatively stable
and predictable so it's rarely A
Difference Maker that that's my only
point and we can anecdotes all day you
know Jim Bob's wife decided to vote
Hillary or what yeah it's that totally
fine but let's do data because you're a
data guy so if you're a data guy tell us
when you're saying it's not necessarily
that the middle one would have had Trump
yeah would he have needed the middle to
get reelected in 2024 in 2020
he would have needed roughly the same
percentage that Republicans tend to need
Trump suffered because they're they're
on on the covet thing would he have
gotten reelected it's not only if covet
didn't happen Trump probably would have
gotten reelected I think if when kovitz
started instead of trump saying we have
15 cases soon going to be zero do flu
vaccines work on covid what about bleach
injections all that stuff if instead of
that Trump said hey you know what we're
the United States we're going to deal
with this better than anybody else we're
making Maga masks and by the way 50
cents on every dollar will go you know
his his normal fundraising scams right
do the scams but do the Maga masks and
if he said we're going to be absolutely
the best on this thing he wins we saw it
in New Zealand we saw it in other places
it was a missed opportunity now I think
it was just a miscalculation in the
sense that somewhere Trump probably
thought it was really going to go away I
don't know who was around him I don't
know who's by Easter of 2020 right I
mean okay so I think Trump even if he
had just done that and because we
decided why would he have why why would
the why would the Independents the ones
in the middle who are uh let's just say
slightly more reasonable and they're
willing to say you know I don't like
this guy on the left I'm gonna vote
right I don't like this guy on the right
I'm gonna vote left yeah why would they
have still chosen Trump over Biden we're
now I have no idea you'd have to talk to
them I just don't know but you're given
you're given your arguments and so your
arguments you're given is you're talking
about uh uh polls like Biden because
America is more respected under Biden
than Trump okay so that has nothing to
do with American voters we're talking
about people in other countries I
totally get it but but when you're when
you say something like that the voter
says oh wow America the world respects
Biden more than they respect Trump sure
okay somebody may say well maybe because
you know anybody who was an enemy of
America hated Trump because Trump would
you know deal more directly with them
than Biden would Biden you can't
necessarily see him you know he doesn't
look like a leader he's not an
obama-esque he's not a Clinton guy Biden
doesn't come across as a strong leader
but you're saying he's more respected
than Trump great no problem okay so then
I go and I ask you a question and I say
if Kobe doesn't happen does he get
reelected yes why you say because more
people show up this whole you know this
whole narrative about the fact that you
need the middle voter to Tipton that's
not true it's how many people show up
and it's his people because his people
don't care if he gets anything done
that's what you said that was your
narrative right that's what you said
those were your words some of those
words mirror the things that I said yes
okay so so it activates which means uh
so Trump's voters so give me when you
say I speak to a lot of these Trump
voters there's obviously a lot of
animosity in you you have a lot of
resentment animosity towards them I
don't know why but you seem angry and
obsessed towards Trump I mean your
comments like you know towards Trump is
Boom you know voters or this voters or
that well to you what problem maybe I
have to I have to interrupt that but I
get that so what is the what is and you
can answer all those questions and I'll
give you your time I'm not remembering
all of them but I'll try to write what
is the DNA of a typical Mega voter in
your eyes there there's not any typical
DNA I think there's basically three
primary categories of people that vote
for republicans and Trump introduced a
fourth fair to introduce these four
categories break it down for us for us
that you know you we don't have your
intelligence well it's not about
intelligence and I don't know if you're
being sarcastic it's not about
intelligence this is your world okay so
this is your world so so you know tell
us what you think about the three and
the fourth I with your intelligence
imagine what you could do if you looked
up the things I look up that's really
the incredible okay no so in all
seriousness four basic groups pre-trump
you had three groups you had sort of
pro-business low tax uh right-wingers
people like Mitt Romney basically they
are I mean Romney maybe isn't a little
bit of an exception because there's a
Mormon he has some socially conservative
views but you've got like your Romney
type who's concerned with let's not over
regulate businesses let's not have taxes
that are too high let's create a good
business environment as governor of
Massachusetts that was sort of uh his
his idea and that's a very blue State
and he did well so you've got like your
Romney type traditional low tax limited
government yeah not Republic uh not
extreme millionaire not extreme rights
and social issues type people
particularly homophobic for example or
you know okay then you've got your more
libertarian-minded people I found it
interesting when you said you're
independent and Libertarians in the U.S
Libertarians are mostly right-wing and
they mostly vote for Republicans so then
you've got your very libertarian-minded
people uh who whose focus is that we
want just as much as much freedom to do
as much stuff as possible it often
includes freedom to discriminate if I
don't want to do you know like a gay
wedding cake that that you've got that
group you then have Evangelical and
religious voters whose primary things
are less economic what was your second
one second one is libertarian
libertarian third you've got your
Evangelical Mike Pence vote if you will
more than Mike Pence vote people for
whom abortion and gay marriage and more
recently you know trans stuff that's
really the most important they'll go
with the economic stuff even though it's
actually often not good for them and you
started to see this under Reagan a lot
where these religious voters they went
with Reagan even though economically it
wasn't the best thing for them those are
typically the three groups you hear you
hear the common term they're voting
against their interests because they
have social uh ideologies they gravitate
towards so you've got those three groups
Trump had all all of that the early Ted
Cruz support in 2016 is that third group
that Evangelical that eventually went to
Trump trump coalesce these groups
because they really weren't going to
vote for Hillary the fourth group which
Trump kind of created is people who were
not at all engaged with politics before
they didn't pay attention they knew
Trump is a celebrity they didn't really
have a political identity they were
disaffected they weren't really
participating before so four is his
personalities what you're saying or yeah
they got brought in specifically he
introduced that that's been around for a
while though he introduced what you're
saying he Trump introduced the fourth
you said typically it's three oh yeah
but Trump introduced the fourth or Trump
has the fourth Trump is
activated this fourth group which was
people who were not in any of those
three categories I mentioned and got
engaged in politics for the first time
because they heard Trump say something
that they liked give some examples of
those type of are you talking about West
Virginia coal miners or people in the
Deep Red South it's there they were from
all over but it was people who like that
Trump was going to fix trade with China
A lot of them didn't really know what
that meant but it sounded pretty good
maybe the person had lost a job they
came to believe it's it's because of
China that I lost my job that sounds
good or people who are on immigration
they're like the wall of course you and
I know you're never building a wall
never mind Mexico is going to pay for it
but there were people who like the idea
never were in politics like no it sounds
good I'm voting for Trump so he brought
in this fourth group
okay so so the fourth group to be exact
it's his personality that people were
turned on by the way he was could be
personality but it could be that there
was one thing he said so so let me ask
the question is there something wrong
with that I'm curious are you going to a
place where this there's something wrong
with that or no it's not about right or
wrong it's a question of whether any of
us think that the
policy motivations for any of those
groups aligned with ours somebody may
say there's a lot of people that showed
up for Obama just because he was black
sure they can say that I don't know I
mean I don't know
you don't think it's true of course in a
country of 330 million people there are
going to be some well you said you don't
know if it's true it's like what do you
mean you don't know if it's true I don't
have any you don't have any data you
want to get data to say people showed up
that they just because they're black
there's exit polling on most of these
issues we might be able to find it right
now you know no it's it's uh you know
it's fair to say people voted for me I
mean I cannot even tell you how many
people
uh uh I know Republicans who were voting
for uh Obama in the insurance industry
just because like listen man the first
time this guy talks like MLK you know he
sounds reasonable I'm gonna vote for the
guy there's a lot of people that came
out with him so somebody may say well
you know the reason why Obama got
elected because he's got the three
difficult things when he talks to the
democrata but the fourth thing is he was
black okay and are you gonna say what I
would say yeah I'm sure that there's a
portion of people who vote so so so
you're saying the DNA of a trump Mega
voter
who looks past policies so you're saying
on the three policies he didn't check
off the three policies here the three
points you're saying that
I I'm saying he didn't build the wall or
I mean let me take a step back with you
so I'm asking a question and I said so
tell me if you're saying he's going to
get reelected without covet you're
saying he would have gone reelected I
think he would have perfect and then you
said your words you said something in
the context of you know because I think
the Maga voter is not about policies
that's what you said a lot of that
fourth group yes is not about
overarching accomplishments or like I'll
give you an example of what I'm talking
about and maybe it'll help to distill it
I got a call at some point during the
first term of trump from a guy who said
I'm voting for this guy this guy is just
the best and I said oh okay what do you
care about what how are you evaluating
his performance to decide if you're
going to vote for him in 2020. like how
do you just I'm curious how do you
decide he said well I care about the
wall so he's he's got to Build That Wall
I said perfect if he doesn't build the
wall are you still going to vote for him
and he says well yeah I'm not going to
vote for a Democrat so I said oh so it
doesn't act actually matter if he builds
the wall same with you as well though
there's no way you're voting for a
republican either would you vote for a
Republican sure yeah I mean if you ever
voted for a Republican president
no I mean okay yeah but hold on a second
but you're 40 years old you're you're
1984 so I'm 38 please 84 38 years old 30
years still you've had plenty of
Elections let's back up for a second
there's two questions would I and have I
I've only voted in a few presidential
election we've had plenty of chances
well but who would I voted for I was
going to vote for George W Bush in 2004
no but it doesn't matter the point is
when you're calling that guy out you're
the same as that guy no I'm not okay so
tell me a republican you'd vote for
you're I don't I think you're missing
the picture what is it the point is he
made a claim that he was going to make a
vote depending on policy and when I then
said so if the policy fails you'll vote
for someone else and he said no actually
the policy doesn't matter that's the
difference I'm not making that claim
yeah okay it's a completely different
thing I mean the same can be said to to
uh to take one example of a story of a
person who sounds like an idiot to say
that and then categorize everybody and
from this selective hearing to say
that's not what I'm doing that's that's
selective for you well you are kind of
doing that you're saying here's a
republican voter who you ask why are you
thinking about voting for Trump oh
because he's building the wall then he
said if he doesn't build a wall well I
would never vote for a Democrat well do
you care if the wall never gets built no
I don't care I'm on vote for him anyways
well that's that's it that's that
doesn't sound like a reasonable voter to
me though that's right he's not a
reasonable well the reasonable voters to
me was also if if you were to ask the
average person who voted for Biden sure
they didn't vote for Biden okay they
voted against Trump okay do you disagree
I'd have to look at exit polls okay so
is that is that where you go to for
something like or a guy who if this is
your space yeah what's your podcast
about
what is it about what's your show about
news in politics you should know this
stuff you're the expert I brought you
don't remember that offhand how do you
find it but this is your world like if
you ask me questions on business I'm
gonna say let me give you my feedback on
what I think about business yeah you
know about my new podcast hey Pat I want
to talk about Paul about business let's
do that I have no problem with it to do
no do that part but what I'm saying to
you is if you're coming here saying what
you're saying sure and then I ask you a
simple question of so the same thing can
be said about people that voted for
Biden yeah I'm just dude I'm gonna vote
for anybody dude nobody would show up
when Biden would speak did you not see
his tour when he was going campaigning
Patrick you're not really doing this are
you tell me you're doing this I'm
actually curious where you're going to
go now Simon wasn't even doing events
where I mean this is the Biden one from
the basement there yeah I have a counter
to this entire and I want to just be
really clear
I don't really care about defending
Biden in any particular sense I just
think he was the better option than
Trump I I feel like I'm being framed as
this Biden lover who's going to defend
everything I'm not doing that you may be
thinking I'm not doing that to you what
I'm asking what I want to say about this
can you pull up Biden's rallies when he
was running for president go ahead let's
see the pictures but go ahead Biden
didn't do a campaign the way Trump did
it and the funniest thing to me neither
has anybody done a like the way Biden's
done it he hit
but hold the guys we're this was during
covid though yes let's back up for a
second look how beautiful that is well
that's these are because
this is really the you're telling me
you're you've seen silly here's what I'm
willing to do here's what I'm willing to
do please I'm willing to give him yeah a
million dollars of my own money right
now to go try to fill up an arena for
what what's the point oh no to show that
nobody is inspired by this guy this is
silly
see what silly is what silly is for you
to assume people voted for Biden they
voted against Trump is what they did no
they did yeah sure yeah but what you
just said I said percentages but it's
your world though this is like if you're
gonna if you're gonna sit here and sell
you know talk about how uh how bad the
the Trump voter is and you let me tell
you you know it's these people all they
care about is is personality outside of
the taxes and all this other stuff and
then I ask you a question I say so why
do people vote for Biden many of them
vote on because they just didn't want
Trump yeah I don't know the numbers on
that you should okay you should know
those numbers what I just don't know
that offhand I mean it's we can look it
up it's why why do I need to memorize
can I make a quick Point can I just get
because there's one thing I want to say
here yeah go ahead this entire Biden hid
stuff it's so it's such a self hit or
hit hid in his basement yeah because
when you talk about the he said though
he hit a lot of times but
okay
if I were on the right I would stop
saying that because it's embarrassing to
Trump that he lost to a guy who hid in
his basement that's not that's the
that's the crazy you're president your
guy Joe Biden is the greatest hide and
go seek champion of all time
is he not he's not your president he's
my president he's our president but he's
your guy he's the guy you're defending
you're defending him right now to say
only that he's better than Trump because
you're making me do this the only reason
that there's no way in a even the
Liberals today are not saying he's
better than uh uh Trump in executing or
taking action or doing anything let's
find out the only the only credit well
at this point you've lost credibility to
talk about posts because you don't even
know what you're talking about when
you're saying well I don't know I don't
know if the people were voting against
Trump let's find the poll so if you if
you can't agree to that Dart know how
many of course they were it's not just
how many any it's if you go on look at
any of these uh uh people who were doing
uh uh what do you call a street to when
they're going talking to people like
interviews yeah it's like hey so tell me
who would you vote here Trump's the
worst I would never vote for him people
didn't want to vote for this guy because
because 99 of the media everybody was
sitting there bashing them not non-stop
that just by the way same thing's gonna
happen with the Santos yeah same thing
happened with bush the only Republicans
Democrats like is ex-presidents who are
now painters that's the only Republicans
Democrats like because they're no longer
a threat Trump's a big threat so for for
for you to say well we now have respect
around the world yeah I don't even know
if I want that I think if there's an
element of competition because I I think
if China has to choose between Trump or
Biden
and China would rather have Biden that's
probably not a good sign for me okay is
it a good sign if Russia wants Trump I
mean this is kind of a silly game right
no but but Russia is not our number one
enemy Russia doesn't control 80 percent
of chips Russia is not as powerful as
people think they are they have a lot of
nukes they lead the world totally get it
but we're seeing right now what's
happening to Russia Russia is more
they're powerful you got to put them up
there they're strong
but China is really really strong in
experience China hates America China
doesn't uh they've publicly announced
what they're going to be doing you know
there's a very big difference between
China and Russia and by the way I'm not
sitting here telling you we got to be
best friends with Russia but if China
likes a president over another one that
is a red flag for me yeah it's not rare
as a view on the American right that is
generally who cares what other countries
think I would almost rather they hate us
that's really common I didn't say that
no no I'm not that's what you're saying
I want to see a poll on that do you have
a poll on that not offhand then why do
you have a poll give me a poll
Patrick but no go give me a poll because
you're that's an anecdote now we can use
this but no you're up in your
conversation but you're not doing that
but that's what you're doing it
you're the political expert on that oh
come on you're the political expert what
you just no you're being silly so I'm
giving you exactly what you've been
doing for the first 30 minutes now it
officially bothers you no no it doesn't
bother me but I think it's silly I think
we don't get anywhere but wait a minute
but what you're saying is that if the
argument you give us said show me a poll
yeah show it to me you can't do it
there's a difference between between
saying that there's a specific opinion
among voters that they were motivated by
a particular reason you have polling on
that we just have to find it you're like
you're like you like to use that but not
when it works against you yeah I didn't
say hate I'm not a hate guy if I was a
hate guy you wouldn't be here today I
didn't say that no you no you said most
Republicans would prefer if uh uh other
countries hated us you're putting you're
assuming I didn't say most run it back
wait you didn't say what I didn't say
most you said there is a contingent on
the right right that actually is
emboldened by if they how small of a
community is that don't know
so you're going to take the exception
are you going to make that argument oh
my God yeah Patrick
I'm I'm I'm for clumped yeah um you and
I both you and Linda Richmond I um
I we've it just we're going tangent
tangent tangent where we can't really
drill down on any one issue I'm saying
to you hate is not if I had hate I would
have not had you on I didn't I describe
that word to you you you said I said
fear
I said fear earlier in the show no no
what I mean is I if if China
prefers any president yeah for example
if McConnell is going to be president
yeah and China wants McConnell over
let's pick a uh I don't know over Tulsi
okay I'm not I'm not McConnell okay if
China wants uh uh uh pick a uh what it
what is her name Liz Cheney if China was
Liz Cheney over
mm-hmm I would be hesitant there okay
because who is the number one enemy
who is the number one enemy actually
curious what you're going to think about
that I don't know this is the part that
I'm not asking polls I don't know about
the term enemy I mean I think in terms
of adversary I think it's I think it's
Russia and China differently in
different ways as we talked about we
depend way more on China for goods that
we enjoy being cheap because they're
made in China rather than here I agree
that confers huge economic power China
Russia in a different way yes it's the
nukes yes it's the more unstable leader
it's also alliances with countries where
Russia's involvement can goad or pull
the United States in in ways that are
both resource intensive and politically
disadvantageous so I think they're those
are the two countries give me I mean
there's there's the Afghanistan
situation
um you could argue Russia I mean with
with Venezuela there's there's issues
there that are more economic relating to
oil which we've talked about
um it's less about products and it's
less about supply chain with Russia
although with energy Russia is a factor
um but I think those are our two biggest
adversaries I don't know if the right
term is enemy I'm open to exploring
whether that's the right term certainly
adversary is the right term I I think
I'm on the same page with you on whether
it's adversary or enemy you know uh keep
in mind I've never taken anything past
ESL in my English so my the word enemy
and adversary may have the same meaning
to me maybe a different meaning for you
fair its opposition is how I see it uh
but I agree but but the part for me is
if a country yeah is overly comfortable
with one and is afraid of imposing pain
on them and kind of backs off a little
bit I want to know a little bit more do
you apply that to every country or only
the countries you're concerned about
like China and what I mean by that is
I'll give you I know what you're going
to go to Russia no no Trump no no no
forget about that yeah I'm just saying
if Denmark prefers Liz Cheney over Pete
Buda judge does that influence your
thinking not necessarily okay fair so
the so what I'm getting at is you're
concerned not in general with the
opinion no I can I'm saying my domain is
main enemies Denmark is not somebody we
don't wake up in the morning worry about
what Denmark that's why I asked the
question yeah and Denmark has never
publicly said by 2025 we're going to be
bigger than America and we're going to
do this they've never said that there's
only a few countries that have said that
that's not one of them so it would be
fair then just to say your concern is
not gen so when I say hey you know what
Spain Portugal Italy France UK Argentina
Tina Chile Colombia you know I give you
this they respect Biden more than Trump
that would not be a concern to you
because they aren't the adversaries
you're concerned um no uh I'm curious
where you're going with this no nowhere
I'm just no I have no hidden agenda all
I'm saying is this here's what I'm
saying let's just say for example let's
say
I don't know
um
a uh SPF same bank Manfred yep if he got
up on the pulpit and for 30 minutes said
great things about you
and then you got up and said 30 minutes
good things about him I'm a little
worried about you
okay so I sit there and I'm saying
interesting I get the concept yeah yeah
that's all I'm saying too okay but it
only applies because it's Sam bankman
freed right of course if you know Kelly
who brought me in here said great things
about me that you would have a different
opinion she's not an enemy she's not an
adversary right yeah yeah okay that's
fair so really there's this small list
of countries where you would say their
opinion is a concern I'm actually really
curious where you're going though just
to say it's not you you acted as though
the general reality no no no I'm not I'm
not I'm not uh uh I'm not sitting here
putting everybody I'm telling you top
enemies okay so who's the third who
concerns you the most at third spot I'm
not sure um I mean you could make the
case that you know there's a there's a
view that it would be one of the
so-called Socialist Communist Nations
like North Korea uh people talk about
you know among the American right
there's big concern about Cuba and
Venezuela I don't really share that
concern I'm not a supporter of either of
those regimes to be clear and I'm glad
to talk about that but I don't really
share that concern I think third
actually is more more difficult to say
Iran yeah Iran Iran is a concern
um not economically
um but it's basically all focused around
nuclear weapons and the possibility of
seeding Terror
um so that's a very different situation
than Russia and very different situation
than than China with third it really
depends on the politics of the person
that you ask and I kind of keep an open
mind on that David why are you not a
socialist
um why am I not a socialist well you say
you're not a social unless if you are no
no no no okay so tell us why are you not
a socialist I'm not a socialist because
I grew up in Argentina right okay well I
was I was five when I moved to the US
but but I mean like uh some of your
family their their supporters of
socialists like who your mom is not a
your mom supports Socialism or no no
where did I get that there's an article
that says about your mom supports
socialism oh oh you that may so okay in
Argentina yeah in the 60s when my mom
when my parents were kids among the
Jewish Community there were Lefty
socialist Jewish groups they were sort
of like nominally socialist and they
were cultural and Etc and my mom
certainly was part of that when she was
12. uh and 14 but no my mom my parents
are so holistic that doesn't mean
anything because my mom's a communist
yeah yeah I'm just curious of where that
came from why why are you not a
socialist I think that the market is a
fine way to direct resources in the vast
majority of areas whether it's sneakers
or automobiles or cell phones I think
that that's absolutely a fine way to
direct resources I see it as an
authoritarian imposition for a
government to come to a business owner
like you or like me and say you must
socialize the ownership of this company
and I I'm against that I don't see any
reason for that I don't see a legal
basis and I don't see a moral basis for
it what I am okay with as a capitalist
right so and I know I saw your
conversation with my friend Kyle
Kolinski and it seemed like you guys
were talking past each other a little
bit on social democracy versus socialism
or whatever
I consider myself a Social Democrat sort
of in the mold of Denmark Sweden etc
those are capitalist countries that have
decided to socialize a couple more
things than we've socialized in the
United States that's really the
difference and and it's capitalism it's
a form of capitalism capitalism to make
the money socialism to spend the money
in a lot of these countries uh no I mean
I I think that's a it's a that's a
common talking point but maybe to like
uh distill it in a way are we all okay
with socializing the military are you
cool with that like in other words we
use taxes so then let me let me ask the
question a different way so it's it's
funny to me just the way a lot of people
on the other side are funny to you when
somebody says I'm not a socialist but
then they defend socialism and go
straight to military on how much it
costs and how much money spent that's
not the direction but I'm just saying
but no but it's not fair to interrupt
something go ahead rebuttal go ahead I'm
not doing go ahead okay are you okay
socializing the military in the sense
that we have one military run by the
government our taxes pay into it and
it's centralized and that's the military
there aren't a bunch of different
there's not you know Patrick's military
and if you want to pay taxes there and
that military might have different goals
than the military in Texas or that would
be crazy right we socialize the military
we have everybody pays their taxes we
have a federal military Fair
keep going do we have that
keep going
we we can't make progress unless we
establish but I'm curious to know where
you're going with this well but because
you said that's not the argument you're
making so curious to know where you're
going the argument I was going to make
was not that we spend too much on the
middle okay so I'm curious what you're
going to say are you okay with the
military being organized the way it is
we pay taxes and then the military has
centralized command and that's the way
it's organized is that okay with you at
the federal level that's the current
system that we have here and does it
bother you or is that okay does it
bother me that we have a uh I don't even
think we have at this point but we can
have a strong military that prevents
future Wars for somebody who lived in
Iran and went through War for 10 years
with Iraq and experience all that yeah
I'd like us to have a strong military
okay and you're okay with it being run
the way it's run we pay tax I don't
think we're running it well right now so
I don't know what you mean by that but
I'm not happy with the way we run it
today I these aren't I these aren't
trick questions I'm cheers let me give a
different example are you okay okay with
the fact that the fire department is
socialized usually at the municipality
you're okay okay are you okay because
because it's Community because it's
where you live yes are you okay with the
FAA being socialized in the sense that
the the traffic air traffic control is
run by the FAA there aren't all these
different air traffic controls where
here's a couple airlines that use one
and then here's a couple airlines that
use another we have the FAA they run ATC
this is what keeps planes from running
into each other our taxes go into it
it's socialized is that okay with you
socialize means we are Distributing the
cost among the people and giving
centralized control to that entity is it
okay am I am I willing to spend a
portion of my taxes not my question for
that yes okay the difference between
where I think you are politically and
someone like me is I'm okay socializing
a couple more things okay so it's really
when where these conversations go off
the rail with allegations of socialism
and and whatever
you're you've just said you're okay
socializing a number of things I
mentioned and there's more right we
could say are you okay with like the VA
that's a socialized medicine I don't
know if you're okay with the VA maybe
you are maybe you're not you and I agree
on socializing a whole bunch of stuff I
want to socialize a couple more and
otherwise everything's the same I don't
know that that makes me socially let me
let me ask you a question David so uh
out of every dollar you make what are
you comfortable being taxed on like
being taken away it depends what I get
for that can I give an example sure okay
my willingness to be taxed would be
greater if for example my or my
daughter's college education were paid
for by those taxes so in a vacuum it's
really hard to answer that question
because it depends what we get okay so
let me ask let me let me continue with
you sure please so uh who do you think
makes better decision for your daughter
you are the government what kinds of
decisions School
what what kind like college just say if
you if you pay me I'm the government but
I'll choose which school she can go to
versus you don't pay me the government
you take that responsibility and you get
to choose to send your daughter to what
school she wants to go to what do you
mean the government chooses but I'm
giving you those those options so
meaning the government says these are
the schools that will pay the tuition
for okay you're talking college and
university I'm talking College okay okay
yeah so I'm assuming that's what you're
talking about you're talking about
public schools I didn't I didn't know
which direction you were going yeah but
but so so okay so but go back to when I
asked you the question I asked the
question I said so what percentage of
your
dollar are you willing to be taxed on
yeah not taxed on just taxed
um and you said it depends on what
happens with uh what I'm paying for
right kind of what you said okay so do
you think
um
I mean is that is that logical do you
agree with that at least in principle do
you well well I think I think you have a
good brain
and a good mind to make better decisions
on what to do with your money than the
government can no but as before we go
into the specific education yeah because
I'm trying to find points of agreement
here because I actually don't think
we're really that far apart on a lot of
these issues are you of the mindset that
just hypothetically are you okay paying
more in taxes if the taxes include fire
police roads bridges are you generally
just have you have you ever lent anybody
money yes but you're not answering my
question but I'm gonna answer too this
is my way of answering you have your way
of answering I'm gonna answer you the
way I'm answering so have you ever uh uh
lent
um the same person have you ever lent
money to somebody a good amount and they
never paid you back fortunately not okay
yeah cool well guess what yeah
I feel the same way you do about giving
money to the government because they
haven't had a good track record of doing
right things with my money no it sounds
like you're saying the opposite I think
I have not had an experience well but
you're wiser good for you have you
haven't had that experience because it
sucks but here's the part uh have you
ever lent your car to somebody and it
didn't work out for you no never
happened to you no I have leases and I
just tell them listen I'm the only
person who can drive I don't even know
if that's true my insurance ever have
allowed somebody to borrow anything from
you yeah have you yes okay give me an
idea something anything something like
that they broke or something like that
whatever you you lend somebody oh I'm
trying to remember and people don't
really ask me for stuff very often like
this is a serious question here man like
the world is relying on you giving the
right answer what have I I mean maybe
when I was like 14 I lent somebody a
Discman and they did are you a video
game guy are you a gamer not really
so what do you do for fun bike read
travel you ever lent a bike to somebody
God no So you you're you're you may not
be no I've left the bike no I've left
the bike okay so have you ever lent a
bike to somebody yes and they jacked it
up no you've never had that happen now
then you're living in a freaking Utopia
that's why you don't understand economy
yet maybe I have undergraduated I know
but that part but that's concerning as
well I mean that probably means I know
less and never mind well no not
necessarily that just means you
programmed it's a different story to
think in one way because that disagree
with you but that part is true a lot of
it would currently programmed and then
deprogrammed well you got when you got
13 to one that's a true Monopoly of
professors on the left to the right
that's a pure Monopoly but let me go
back to the question what I'm asking you
asked me the question are you
comfortable you know as long as what
they do with the money that wasn't my
question what was your question my
question was as a general principle yeah
are you okay paying a little more if you
get more same question for Amaya is this
the same thing uh here's why the answer
is no Okay the reason why the answer is
not love your sarcasm the reason why the
answer is no is because if I give
somebody a relative a thousand bucks
okay it's the last thousand dollars
gonna give me I'm telling you bro I'm
gonna pay you back 1500 bucks in two
years yeah never get it back okay two
years later you come back to me hey this
time give me five thousand but I promise
you I'm gonna fix I'm gonna give it back
10 grand yeah okay no here you go two
years later he comes back up dude this
time I'm asking for 10 but I'm changed
right I'm good bro trust me give you the
money I'm gonna fix it
if you give it the third time you're an
idiot in my eyes we keep giving money to
people with zero accountability and we
just keep saying here he goes what are
you talking about 1.9 trillion dollars
but you know for what programs any
programs any programs that were given
money to that there's no accountability
for which is being wasted any one of
them military include any of the
entitlement programs that we have like
which one include welfare include food
stamps include any one of them we can
pull it up and I'll tell you right now
any one of them what I don't understand
is
what do you mean by there's no
accountability can I give an example
please because I think what you're
trying to say is that you don't know
where I'm going with this is an issue
well because so so what you're saying is
you know exactly what happens with the
money when you give it to when you pay
taxes no I just don't understand what
you're talking about you really don't
know what I'm talking about let me give
you something can I just give one
example and then we can open this up and
you guys can have fun doing what you're
doing what I think you are saying is
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me and I think what Patrick is
alluding to is the fact that we are now
at 30 trillion dollars in debt okay and
the fact that we keep want to pile keep
piling on this issue of like I get it we
all need military we need the police we
need the firemen we need all these
social systems we need a social safety
now we need welfare we need Medicaid we
need Medicare I think what his point is
is like at what point is enough enough
now we want to pile more stuff into our
storage unit that has already filled to
the brim and we need to keep piling and
filing and piling more and at one point
is he saying can we stop funding the
government this way because it's not
it's not a good look for us because
we're at 31 32 35 trillion and what he's
saying I think is like we're gonna have
to make some cuts and make some
adjustments okay and you're saying let's
double down let's let's let's keep
adding some of this I didn't say that no
I'm just I'm like you want to add more
systems you said I I think you said I
want one or two more no but wait a
minute you really didn't understand what
I just said did he not understand it I'm
asking you did I want to get to just a
very specific example of a specific
program that you're displeased with
buddy anything so you're against all
government programs I didn't tell you
all government programs so which ones
are you against if you if you if you
give money into programs that you're
coming out saying hey we're going to
spend 88 million dollars for this okay
if you want me to pull it up and we can
go through expenses and tell you which
ones works and which one doesn't we can
do that as well if that's what you want
to do uh but if you constantly come to
me for more money
let me just put it to you this way yeah
what does it mean when a company or an
individual is in debt two hundred
thousand dollars when a company or when
an individual okay let's just say I'm in
the 200 000 okay
and it was a hundred thousand dollars
five years ago okay
it was fifty thousand dollars ten years
ago yeah it was ten thousand hours
fifteen years ago I come to you for
another fifty thousand dollars should
you lend it to me probably not no what
are we doing
what are we doing we're Landing you're
in our taxes it sounds like your
analysis but we're lending our taxpayer
money and we keep getting getting into
more and more and more and more in debt
if the government was an individual or a
corporation
I don't understand why investors keep
giving this government more money when
they have no cash the critical answer is
the government and countries are not
like households or companies that's the
difference it's just it's not an energy
that's not true not analogous that's not
true that's not true though so meaning
it's okay for us to keep going into debt
that's okay that's that's not what I'm
saying so what is different important to
have a balanced view that when it comes
to and what's crazy about this is I'm
not advocating for getting more and more
into debt right Trump did a great job of
it blowing up the deficit the deficit we
still have a positive deficit it's
slightly lessons
generally speaking increases but first
make the argument on how different it is
to to give the analogy yes of personal
household that it's okay for the
government to increase its debt but not
on the personal side
it's okay it's not it's not the same and
what I'm struggling with Patrick is that
like everything I'm saying is just being
relayed to me usually interrupting me
incorrectly so now I'm having to clean
up what you think I said to then answer
the original thing my point is so those
three are different things they are
different explain why they are different
things explain with a household or
corporate
budget or debt you at some point at the
end of the day don't have any more
recourse to carry the debt and you
either have to declare bankruptcy or you
have to all the things that you you you
know with a country of course if the
economic growth becomes decoupled from
the growth in the national debt that is
a problem we've seen it in many many
countries but in the United States and
again I'm not saying who cares about the
dead or the deficit but I think we have
to appreciate that there's a difference
if your economy keeps growing if that
national debt grows more or less in
parallel with the growth of the economy
and it continues to be backed you don't
get to that day where there is the
you're now being evicted crisis that an
individual has that doesn't mean I want
to let me say this one more time I'm not
saying the debt doesn't matter there are
people who say it literally I'm not
saying here's the question okay so but
let me let me kind of try to give the
point of uh uh the example I want to
give to you yeah so what is a sign when
an institution keeps increasing its debt
what sign is there so if I keep getting
fatter
is it because I'm a big bone person or
it's because I may have a bad diet and
not exercising what do you think uh I
guess
I forgot you personally I'd have to ask
your doctor if you you're a small uh
bone guy you don't seem like you're you
were big when you were have you ever
been 200 pounds no okay now so if you
all of a sudden next time you come on
the podcast you're 250 pounds you should
be concerned so can you accidentally
become 250 pounds uh accident it would
be a number of accidents in a row
exactly which by the way you probably
enjoyed your dinner you probably enjoyed
your food right but if you came back 250
pounds yeah as a friend or even somebody
that's in the similar space that we're
creating content right should I off
camera say hey bro what's up I would
appreciate it if you do okay I should do
your father you got a kid I'd like you
to be around for your daughter
statistically or better society when we
are right okay so if you
come to me and I'm smelling bad I'm not
shaving I love it I have nothing and I'm
getting worse week after week after week
should you question and say Pat is that
then okay I think so yeah I think it's a
good idea these are fun examples I'm
trying to have fun with you different
but no it's not talking about if a
country yeah keeps increasing its debt
yeah year after year after year after
year after year right should we not be
concerned we should be concerned about
whether we're spending money in the
right ways we should be concerned about
whether but let's give them another 1.9
trillion dollars we're saying that
that's the thing you know I I don't but
you are saying that because you said the
only difference when you went to your uh
uh example of military yeah and you
wanted me to say yes and you said look
every I'm not a socialist because I
think this and he said the only
difference is I just want two or three
more programs and what I'm saying is we
can't afford it today okay maybe in 20
years but do you are and and I I worry
that I don't know if you think I'm
talking and back bad faith or if you
maybe don't understand my political
views but I think differences that are
actually much more subtle than you think
they are are being blown up as if
there's this crazy difference here about
what's going on we're definitely using
different rhetoric in this conversation
but I don't I don't know whether we're
actually understanding each other really
that well because I'm with you if there
are programs that are wasteful how do we
Define wasteful right that's that's the
difficulty but if there are programs
that are wasteful if there are programs
that are not economically stimulative if
there are programs that are uh being
used for fraudulent reasons or or
whatever the case I'm going to be right
there with you saying we need to do
something about this the the things I'm
looking at when they are done in other
countries yeah the country doesn't
become socialist you can still own your
business they don't socialize your
business they don't they don't communize
your business none of those things
happen many of these countries have
really good business and environment but
they're just saying hey we have enough
riches here that this capitalist system
has created which I'm in favor of where
we can do a couple more things what I'm
saying to you is you don't want it no
it's not what I'm saying to you that I
don't want it yeah
if I if you can stop interrupting this
entire damn show that is freaking you
know it's not fun is it God I'm used I'm
good with it it's part of a uh having
conversations with people who doesn't
offend me but uh if if I sit there and I
say yeah David we can't afford it right
now okay I would say what do you mean I
would tell you it's called 31 trillion
dollars okay is what it's called we're
in debt a lot of debt okay and you may
not have to pay it back somebody has to
pay it back your seven-year-old's gonna
have to pay back but that money's not
going to print a month seven month old's
gonna have to pay back someone's gonna
pay it back yeah okay that 31 trillion
dollars you're not just one they're
gonna say guys let's just write this
thing off you guys okay China hey Japan
you cool let's just write this thing off
and just forget about it and let's start
again yeah how cool would that be we
can't do that we have that we can't
afford it right now one of the things
about a lot of these issues is first of
all they're way bigger than any
conversation where we just like list the
programs and say we cut if you look
historically countries don't cut their
way to economic Prosperity countries
tend to grow their way to economic
Prosperity you you with me so far yes
come countries grow their way out of
economic Prosperity no that's the
opposite of what I said come countries
grow their way into economic Prosperity
they grow by building one too many times
so let's keep getting into that is what
you're saying no that's not what I'm
saying so what are you saying what I'm
saying is over the long term if the
government spending is economically
stimulative it will help to grow the
economy it's fundamental demand side
economic so like as an example there are
certain government programs that are
highly are these cigars by the way I
just noticed this over here you can take
it um if countries uh spend money on Pro
I I don't know you seem to be looking
something up I don't know if you're
paying I'm listening I'm listening to
you go ahead if countries spend money on
economically stimulative programs yeah
the high economic multiplier they can
create growth if countries spend money
in ways that are not economically
stimulative then it increases the debt
so for example just to pick two
different programs I don't have any
emotional attachment to these two
programs I'm just going to list two
programs food stamps and what is
happening in here by the way or are
those gummies yeah taking vitamins man
this is healthy for you I know I don't
want to be the 400 pound guy food stamps
have a high economic multiplier okay tax
cuts for the very rich have a low
economic multiplier I'm not passing any
judgment in any way I'm just telling you
there are ways that the government can
spend money that is good for the economy
and ways that is not so good that's my
only point
what were the two programs you said you
wanted to add on I think we should have
some kind of minimum Level Health Care
system for everybody and it would it
would actually be cheaper than what we
have what we have includes people that
go to the emergency room as primary care
which is insanely expensive sometimes
they don't pay their bills and that
leads to everybody who does have health
insurance is just absorbing that cost it
would just be cheaper if we provided
everybody some basic level of care there
are states that have done it I think
that's just a basic thing
um and secondly I would like to
socialize some aspect of paid
um uh family leave
parental and and maternal not hugely
expensive it's economically at least
stimulative in the sense that when other
countries have done it they find that
productivity ends up being higher when
parents return to work and you know it's
been been widely studied these are just
like two two things we're already paying
for most of them either in terms of
productivity losses or through the
health care that we pay afford to absorb
people who don't pay and use the
emergency room it can be done you know
Revenue neutral what what percentage
like if going back to it with what we
have right now the way it is today yeah
what percentage of your dollar are you
comfortable paying in taxes one percent
really less than Abe Lincoln imposed no
listen I'm not I'm not going this has
nothing to do what I'm telling you yeah
no hold up a different story
um well what percent are you willing to
pay today I am not a high tax guy with
high tax High tax I mean listen
um I don't want to get too much into my
my personal finances but like I don't
like I'm not auditing you bro I don't
like this simple question I don't like
that close to half of my income is going
to taxes you don't like it I think it's
too high so what do you think is
reasonable oh man Does it include Health
Care in college or not
I I would love to be in the you know 31
total just so you know we're on the same
page there yeah okay so for me the
difference is the following yeah uh uh
one time I'm doing a podcast uh I don't
know who I'm doing a podcast with
anyways this was like a year and a half
ago sounds explosive and then no it
wasn't actually you know you know what I
like about podcasts like this yeah it
makes me go uh research a topic you know
so one time we did a podcast about taxes
and you know how taxes at one point
ninety percent you know it was a 90
taxes and it was like for a long time
Hollywood was this is what they're doing
this is what it was like so you're
talking about a 90 marginal on the very
top incomes Under Ice correct and I make
my point without you freaking intellect
with degrees to interrupt freaking high
school graduate that's ad hominem okay
all right so let me go back to this with
these two Jews bullying me right now uh
so so so we're talking about taxes yeah
okay so I said let me go find out what's
going on with taxes here in the history
of it okay so we send our research team
and I said send me anything yet on taxes
you can assume this was like a very
exciting uh two weeks of my life just
studying taxes it was awesome great
experience I can only imagine what it's
like to want to be an accountant it's
got to be like a you know fascinating
experience High suicide High School
accountants you know do you know what
happened to you know the one data that
came about on when taxes got started the
history of tax you know the whole story
yeah it is all this I'm not going
through that part but I want to find out
because a lot of people on the left say
you can't compare governments to
companies to you know families you can
it just might not be useful but meaning
it's not the same thing you can't do
that financially all this other stuff
yeah so you see the Lincoln thing that
you know story pops up where you know
back in 1861 this guy goes up and says
hey us we kind of need some money yeah
this war was so expensive for us we're
gonna have to tax everybody six percent
yep but I promise you when we pay it off
we'll stop taxes do you know what
happened well after they paid it off the
taxes didn't end no it ended no they
didn't let me read this one
so so watch this here okay on August 5th
1861 Lincoln imposed the first federal
income tax by signing the Revenue Act
strap for cash strapped for cash which
the government is kind of like they
don't have cash they're in debt yeah so
they're they need cash just like a
corporation or family we don't have cash
so we need some debt with which to
pursue the Civil War Lincoln and
Congress agreed to impose a three
percent tax on annual incomes over 800
bucks
as early as 1861 Lincoln had began to
take stock of the federal government's
ability to wage war against the South he
sent letters to cabinet members Edward
Bates Gideon Wells and Salman Chase
requesting their opinions as to whether
or not the president had the
Constitutional authority to collect
duties according to documents housed and
interpreted by Library Congress Lincoln
was particularly concerned about
maintaining Federal authority over
collecting revenue from ports along with
along the Southeastern Seaboard which he
worried might fall under the control of
Confederacy the Revenue Act language
okay uh uh according to the U.S treasury
Department the compare comparable
minimum tax income in 2003 after
adjustment for inflation would have been
around sixteen thousand dollars Congress
repealed Lincoln's tax law in 1871 which
means there was no more taxes but it
came back up obviously in 1909. so
this is an example of a story where we
need some money let's go to the people
the people say listen here's some money
but I hope this stops it's going to stop
so the moment we allow the government to
use this power too much they've abused
it okay and for me my only argument is
if I have to choose between giving you a
million bucks that's going to sound
crazy okay I hope this doesn't get your
head too big and you get too confident
here please if I give you a million
bucks or if I give a million bucks to
the government I'm willing to bet you're
probably going to create you know a
better climate with a million dollars
and the government would and if I have
the choice to give a million dollars or
billion dollars to creators job creators
small business owners on what they can
do as a source of investment versus
giving that money to the government
government if there was a FICA score if
if there was a FICO score I don't know
what your FICA scores but you know the
range 400 High extremely high 400 to 820
give or take that's the number what's
that if we had to give a FICO score to
the US government what do you think
their FICO score would be today yeah but
he needs polls give me the polling on
that no listen here I mean what you're
saying is super interesting I do you
know the point I'm making now
and here's one of the things that that I
think
we I'm guessing we would probably agree
on which is when you think about
um the the way that we organize Society
this isn't politics this is just like
sociology philosophy kind of like
reality once you get a group of people
bigger than about 150 150 people okay if
you want that to be run in some way that
works what we might Define as works you
have to start introducing some level
some level of centralization that
doesn't mean with 150 people you need
the tax system and everything that we
have right now but it's just kind of
like a reality of organizing societies
that as societies grow from 150 people
and think about it 330 million people
now in the U.S 8 billion people in the
country there the idea that you have
which is I'll just pick some people to
give a million bucks to instead of the
government it's that it just doesn't
work that's it that's it that's some
things have to be said we're having fun
with you buddy when I'm telling you that
but the point I'm trying to make that
the idea is an interesting one no
the point I'm trying to make to you is
that's how the US government was ran
yeah
the country you and I are living in yes
it was ran that way guys we don't have
money we go to the people I promise you
once we pay this off we're going to stop
taxing you yeah and we accepted it you
know no taxation so this we accept we're
like totally fine with this we're game
with this and then now it's peer abuse
we don't have a choice now like we did
back then yeah it was ran like a company
it was ran like a family having their
finances in order today America's FICO
score is in the 400s you know in the
400s what you should be able to finance
nothing I don't know 60 down 30 percent
it's at 400 it should be a hundred
percent down but so what what would you
want so you were you you said you were
with me on like low 30s for taxes I am
okay yeah so really it sounds like the
issue is more I would I would want to
flat tax and what I'm saying I would
want a flat tax meaning I'd like to go
somewhere between 10 or 15 to 33 and a
time to go to that they're not flat is
it I get that but what I'm saying is if
America like right now we need to pay
off debt guess what yep attacks me 33
okay but let's gradually pay some of
this stuff off I would like for them to
say we're gonna go off a budget of 25 or
20 the 13 every we're going to pay off
the debt okay but here's a problem yes
you know why they'll never never happen
well there's a lot of reasons I mean I
don't know I'll give you my congressman
people will never win uh
agenda if we have no term limits these
guys are going to play whatever games
too you're for term limits are you cute
oh me too absolutely you kidding me yeah
guys we just found some common ground
with David Pacman Patrick about David
term limits on the agenda my challenge
isn't a you know my challenge is we're
giving money to people that have proven
to have no clue what to do with it and
the debt keeps climbing now when it
comes to like social safety net right
can I tell you my view on this stuff and
you tell me if you agree right I moved
to the us as an immigrant okay
I had the benefit if my parents had to
pay for my initial schooling like if
they had to pay out of pocket for
elementary school or whatever the case
may be that you know my mom wasn't
working at the time my dad was just
starting a job where he didn't make a
lot of money they couldn't have afforded
if that public school said we're gonna
charge you right so I immediately got
the benefit of that
follow along right I got the benefit of
police protection and then eventually
all these different things contract so
when I started my show intellectual
property so the way I see it is I've
been extraordinarily fortunate to be
able to build my business and get to
where I am thanks to a whole bunch of
things that everybody paid for through
taxes so my view now is I'm all let me
finish up I'm also okay like I recognize
you know I've got these great employees
many of them had Public School
educations and they have certain
protections when it comes to Safety in
the world you should be able to do all
that with no more than 30 well no I'm
not I'm not even getting to three but so
I feel it's almost like a patriotic
thing where if taxes are properly set
and being spent on the right things I
think now my success which only exists
because of previous taxpayers through
all those programs I mentioned it should
go to help other people who don't have
that's the wrong mindset in my opinion
okay and let me tell you why things are
wrong mindset because uh okay
you ever had a job have I ever had a job
well yeah no you don't have a job right
now your business owner have you had a
job oh yeah yeah yeah okay did do were
you there for five years like did you
work for a company for five years yeah I
mean this is kind of funny but I worked
for the now defunct retailer Circuit
City for five years really yeah selling
extended services they pay very well but
I don't know when you work very well in
the commission I got laid off when they
went from commission to hourly yeah the
people who were making too many
commissions they didn't want to pay a
salary they laid us off check this out
okay so let me let me see if what year
was it you work in a Circuit City it
ended in 2003 so it would have been like
the era by the way can you tell
everybody how much a good salesperson at
Circuit City was making
well if you remember because I I I'm
willing to say this I worked part-time
because I was like starting College
check this out 30 hours a week and I was
making 75 000. that's insane yeah at
Circuit City yeah okay they realized it
was insane and they're like we're not
paying these people but that's [__]
though that's [__] though because
that's why they went out of business
right the model was working you guys
were doing your part came up dude Best
Buy 37 bucks an hour you're about to
validate my points so check this out
this is a perfect example here the
perfect example is here so for me
you know how you go to a funeral and
everybody's morning and maybe you don't
know the person but you're going because
it's somebody or you don't have a role
like it's in law or somebody like that
sure but just depend on everybody's face
you feel it right
so for me when I hear a company going
out of business right breaks my heart
especially company that has been on for
a long time because to start a company
it's a very hard very very hard to start
a company to make it last five past five
years super hard right 10 20 30 years
and then create hundreds if not
thousands of jobs it's not easy to do
somebody and a group of people had to
sacrifice a lot right okay so what
you're saying is the following hear me
out okay so the people who started
Circuit City yeah okay those who start
at Circuit City those who paved the way
before you and they came and they
crushed it and now there's new
management and now because the people
before you paved the way you should
accept lower salary to give back to the
people that paved the way before but
it's not the people before that paved
the way it's the people today that are
running Circuit City you're actually not
giving back to the people that paved the
way you're giving it to the idiots that
are running Circuit City today that's
what's going on in America today meaning
you and I I love America I love I lived
in around 10 years I lived in Germany
two years I was in the military and I
come from a family politically on
complete opposite sites but I love this
place it's an amazing country
my responsibility
on how I can contribute to society isn't
through paying taxes it's through
creating jobs it's through you know when
I pay my taxes I pay a lot of taxes this
year a lot of taxes this year last year
was a lot of taxes I've been paying a
lot of taxes period so but for me when I
pay the taxes and I ask where did that
thing go to okay what happened with that
what are they doing with that if they're
doing such a great job with it why does
the debt keep going higher why are we
you know keep uh not seeing any kind of
return things are still same thing both
of them are not asking to raise more
money oh it's only the left you know the
Democrats that just want to go no that's
not it's it's both of these sides who
are part of the same camp another 1.9
trillion another two trillion another
2.7 trillion I'm not for it okay so all
I'm saying to you is the same way the
Circuit City folks ruined the great job
you had making 75 grand you're working
30 hours a week yep they came the new
management decided to change the
compensation compensation structure that
was working that's the perfect example
of a Circuit City went out of business
same thing that a lot of politicians are
doing today yeah it doesn't seem at all
analogous to me but I love talking about
selling extended service plans so we can
stay on Circuit City if you want but in
all seriousness it doesn't seem
analogous to you it doesn't really seem
oh really so let me ask you a question
why does Circuit City go out of business
well let's see
um I'm thinking back now they went out
of business because when they switched
people from commission to hourly they
got rid of the people that were doing
really well because they didn't want to
pay us the hourly equivalent wow so they
got rid of the entrepreneurs they got
rid of it no so so it's not analogous at
all they got rid of the people that are
self-motivated people got it so that
that is actually the perfect example
because they changed the comp plan they
increased taxes for the people that were
working that's not at all analogous they
didn't increase taxes they just laid me
up at the 75 000 people make 75 000
again after they change account no they
did not at a different job not at a
Circuit City Circuit City you're
laughing because you see the points they
left to a different place but then you
got a new job and started making more
money but the point is people this is
why people leave with California I was
just gonna say it's not exactly what's
going on in New York and California
that's the cause of high tax states to
come to low tax states so I mean we can
talk about high and low tax states the
effective tax rate especially if you own
cars and homes in a lot of places ends
up being very close yeah
let's get off of circuits no I don't
want to get off of Circuit City stay on
this point because okay that is the
point though David that's the point but
I am I'm trying to have a different
Quest a conversation sure you are I'm
trying but not because it's a more
advantageous conversation because you're
saying it's not analogous what I just
want to know from you is I get it with
the company the Circuit City deserves to
go out of business and it was allowed to
go out of business and that was great
I'm with you because they made a
terrible business decision I'm
completely with you what I'm asking you
is on a human level in a country country
as rich as the United States
330 million people all these different
things I'm not saying no one should be
rich I'm not saying taxes should be 60
I'm not saying anything I'm just saying
for the little comparatively that it
would take just to make sure that
there's no hungry kids for example the
little little thing you don't have to go
to the ER when you have a problem you
could isn't that much related to you
isolate this we can go to that stay on
this issue don't digress stay on this
issue by the way just out of curiosity
who's your guy like when you were who do
you look up to what what comedian guy
your style do you look up to I just I
just wrote a name down because you
remind me I don't know you sure you
don't have Heroes you don't have
comedians you like no David you got
someone you like I'm just this guy
doesn't lend money to people he doesn't
lend people their cars and he doesn't
have anybody celebrities
you didn't have anybody you watched like
a Bill Maher guys like that that used to
I like this guys like I'm a big Bill
Maher guy I love Chappelle no so I mean
I casually would watch Bill Maher but I
mean are you a Jon Stewart guy are you a
you know I like I would watch John's
here a little bit so let's go back to
Circuit City okay
it was my technique for selling the
service plan yeah do you want to know
that no okay you're staying on Services
it's digressing but we can stay on
circuit but do you know why I'm staying
on this topic no okay let me let me this
this is this is there's a metaphor here
I promise you in the business world yeah
okay when a guy or person leaves a
company yes they leave for a reason in
the sales industry many times they leave
because comp changed okay so what
happens with comp this is what typically
happens with comptour sales people a guy
sits there this is 2003 you said that's
what 2016. I believe so holy [__] you're
seven you're making 75 out of 18. yeah
okay so check this out I got in this you
want to really know a crazy story I was
that's why I love Circuit City Stories I
was audited because it wasn't plausible
that I was making that much and so a guy
show a I showed up an investigator with
a with a recorder and they're like so
where exactly did you make this it was a
crazy thing my mom sat with me my mom
sat I was like Mom I don't know
I know I know a lot about the Circuit
City folks because I recruit a lot of
circuit city folks and after that
happened to the insurance industry but
but this is something well here's the
part though because you guys were sick
Circuit City sales training was awesome
same was Bally Total Fitness by the way
I'm a Bally's guy okay so Circuit City
is sitting there and they're saying
who the hell is this Pac-Man guy we're
paying 75 grand you're working 30 hours
a week and he's 18. right he shouldn't
get paid that correct we should only pay
him six bucks an hour yes there's no way
this guy's worth we're overpaying them
some idiot at the top said what we're
overpaying them yeah okay so they came
up with this idea that let's fire these
guys that have charm Charisma sarcastic
witty people like him they're selling
awesome who cares if you make 75. they
flipped it on him yep that happened to
me when I was at your when I was 21 I
just got out of military so people had
Bally's at one point were making 180 200
Grand year in the 80s in the 90s sales
people by the way Circuit City was
paying 180 200 EUR to sales people
Circuit City was killing it was like one
guy making that much well one guy per
place in Connecticut no no no no there
was no one in our store making that much
well maybe not your store but there's a
lot of guys that were making money on
circus if you're 30 years old making 75
there were plenty of guys that were
making money 18 years I'm sorry 18 years
old making 75. a lot of people were
making money a circus doing sales so
here's the point please guy changes to
come yep he lost you okay you get fired
you go elsewhere you do other things yep
did a lot of other people leave
well anybody making under 10 an hour in
commissions was too bad of a salesperson
they got rid of him anybody making over
20 an hour there were two people in our
store I was one of them they got rid of
us so they only kept those 10 to 20. so
they kept them before average why
socialism doesn't work
now you want to flip it don't you no no
no your truth so think about that
socialism would be you've got to keep
the ones around actually it's not
socialism is social average social just
crazy this is a great conversation about
things completely disconnected from 100
but I love the conversation they're 100
connected is what they are 100 connected
because it's like saying if you tax
people less hey wait a minute elon's
making too much money these billionaires
are getting too rich these millionaires
are getting too rich this is not good we
need well tax we need this we need that
no way we should be doing this hey you
know when elon's saying something in uh
in uh whatever was in California and the
mayor responded back and he says okay
noted boom I don't know if you remember
this now do you remember when the the
mayor or yeah
Silicon Valley we should do away with
him he's like all right God we should do
away with test line they're this and
Elon is this like and got his tweets
back and says no doubted moves to Austin
great guess what Austin got Elon a lot
of people Florida got a lot of great
talent Texas got a lot of talent people
leave when you change comp planes I'm
sitting here giving you the example of
where taxes are good 33 we're on the
same page okay I'm willing to go 33
you're saying 30 31 which you're a
little greedy I got to tell you well I'm
a greedy socialist this is so this is so
uh first of all come on yeah okay but
are you an Elon fanboy
not as much as your Joe Biden boy Fanboy
no because you're you're a die hard I
would be interested if I would have
known I would have got you sure it's
obvious you you love uh seriously no
what's not now why is it seriously are
you a podcast said why do you have a
painting of Biden in the back oh okay
okay so all right okay go ahead what is
your thought because I was a relatively
early Tesla investor and I still drive a
Tesla I think it's gonna be my last one
I've sold the shares are where are you
on Elon because a couple people wrote to
me they're like oh uh Patrick's Fanboy
or on Tesla either okay so
foreign
can I take a sip yeah is that an energy
drink now it is owned by Tesla by the
way too yeah
no it's not I don't but by the way while
he's drinking this why are you done with
Tesla why is this your last Tesla the
reason and are you on not Elon Musk
Fanboy I have no emotional thought
whatever about Elon okay so here was my
thought okay when I got the Tesla shares
in 2015 I thought
Electric's coming early mover range and
charging network are the things that
matter this is gonna set them up they're
gonna it's gonna be crazy
so I bought the shares eventually I got
one of the cars I was like this is
fantastic once you buy shares when when
2015 26 February 2016 I think it was so
I get the car I'm like unbelievable
range fantastic the charging Network all
this stuff the build quality kind of
sucks everything's rattling there's
things that are held together seems to
be by tape but that's okay I like I get
it they haven't been building cars very
long they're gonna it's gonna improve
it's gonna improve got the second Tesla
better build quality still it's the same
issue four times now every time it's
literally something that has to be
ratcheted has to be taken apart now the
other companies that let's be honest
Audi builds better cars than Tesla
they've been doing it for a hundred
years they don't rattle Etc they're
losing the charging network advantage
slowly partially thanks to the inflation
reduction Act and the the high speed
here we go spokesperson for Biden and
also
um the range there's more and more cars
now that are matching the range so I
think the time that first mover
Advantage is diminishing drive so David
if if somebody didn't know either one of
us yeah and they had to pull yep to to
say who's a Elon Fanboy it would be you
why here's why you're against all of it
can I can I can I answer why are you
such a bully let me answer man uh one
I've never owned the Tesla okay two I
don't own Tesla stock I've never bought
Tesla stock okay okay because I thought
it was always overpriced wow okay uh but
here's what I will tell you please as a
jockey I'm a fan of the Jockey him being
the jockey the business I thought Tesla
too many people who were Fanboys who
thought that it's just because it's him
it's going to kill it it's down 85 for
the year but the point is it's at the
right number right now it's around the
number it should be give or take maybe
it's still not at the number it needs to
be but long if it's a long investment I
think it's a good long investment I
think a lot of people got killed last
year by the way a lot of people made you
know money last year as well Citadel Ken
Griffin made 16 billion last year you
don't make 16 billion during a flat
economy or even slightly down you make
it because you were shorting certain
stocks and some of the famous stocks to
short last year hence the company and
the boy you love the most you know your
guy Elon Musk okay
but on paper but he's done you're a
fanboy I'm out of the stock and I'm
getting out of the car so you're an
ex-fan boy is what you are it's okay I
mean it's nothing wrong with that the
product yeah was had a specific
Advantage never been a ton of the
product I've never been a fan of the
product I've never been one that has
gone my but by the way my best one of my
best friends every time he named his son
Elon well that's qualified okay he owns
Teslas
stocks all of it total fan of that stuff
I'm not that camp yeah what I do like is
the following just so you know when you
leave this place you best say thank you
to Elon okay you owe him a thanks okay a
big thanks have you enjoyed the the
session we've had today together yeah is
this a good day for you yeah I mean
listen I don't know that I think we
talked past each other a lot okay and
things that are not actually
disagreements were zoomed in on and and
I think we would actually get along on
80 of stuff if the conversation was not
for television potentially did you watch
Kyle's uh uh show when Kyle and I were
together or no I watched some of it okay
you know how much fun I had with Kyle no
it's the same I had a lot of fun with I
have no idea how much fun by the way if
you told me you are willing to come back
next month you're on next month I I
enjoy the sauce so you don't one thing
you need to know if you should I don't
look at comments anymore the comments on
this from your audience are going to be
brutal I'm going to need a new therapist
I'm gonna need a new therapist I
actually think I actually think they
like you a lot of as well trust me and
here's why they're with our audience the
reason with our audience is because we
like people like that to come we don't
want like by the way you know who's
going to be on Thursday you ready for
this one I I don't know like the
complete opposite of you I guess it's
going to be Ben Shapiro
is it worse James O'Keefe is going to be
on Thursday from uh from uh Veritas oh
my God yeah so he's going to be honest
but if I'm sure you guys would like to
have lunch together and have a good time
together I'll still be here I'll swing
by so but but here's the point here's a
baby we said something the point the
point I want to make too is on on the
topic of differences and all you said he
was going to has to thank Elon for
something yeah because without Elon you
and I wouldn't have tweeted each other
he's running Twitter right now uh you
know we tweeted each other last year I
know we did but you know again what does
that have to do with Elon it's a
connection we have through Twitter that
he's running now
a year ago it had nothing man I'm giving
this guy credit because it's a bad boy
to find a reason to thank Elon for
something I'm looking listening attitude
I'd like to find reasons to be thankful
for people right now who is a bigger
Elon Musk Fanboy there is no way or
Patrick but but if you want to say like
in an area that I believe in what he's
gonna do as a jockey okay yeah I I
believe in him as a jockey so if if I'm
gonna if I'm on a long anything I'm
gonna along what he's gonna be doing
investment by the way I really
appreciate the metaphor that you're
using right now
of the horse versus the jockey the horse
in this instance
guys we are finding common ground here
in Peabody the other analysis Circuit
City you didn't believe in is is the
Circuit City did have a little analysis
level I think if we don't Dove deeper it
falls come on bro that's like
you dropped like it's as if I wanted to
say it but you said it they got rid of
the top guys and the bottom guys to make
the middle guys happy that's socialism
it's not it's social they do this does
something for the bottom hours later
saying he's not a socialist folks he's
defending socialism okay but so the
reality is Circuit City did shut you
know what would be a cool shirt here
would be a cool shirt here's what would
be a cool shirt oh wait for it can you
pull up this book called first-rate
madness pull up the book to cover I have
an idea I have an idea for uh our
Frontier I've got a book that I'm
working on so maybe I I could take this
and this will be the cover let's see I
don't know if you want to use this cover
but it's a it's a so pull up that you
see that cover right there First Rate
Madness yeah part of it is Kennedy okay
yeah part of it is uh uh and the other
one is I don't know who the bottom left
one is could be Jackson because they
talk about him a lot it's not Sinatra uh
are you being sarcastic no I'm kidding
yeah okay no I think we should get a
picture like that mate and I'll tweet it
out today just because I like you I
think it should be half the face should
be Biden okay the other quarter should
be Bernie and the last quarter should be
Elon Musk as a fanboy for him and I'm
gonna say David this art was create can
you by the way can you tell our graphic
design I'm sure he's going to talk [__]
all day today we're gonna have a good
time like that's a gift for me to you I
don't know what we're talking about but
it sounds interesting yeah what was the
name you wrote down describing David
he's Jon stew this guy's talented I like
it I like it you look like Jon Stewart
you've never heard before people say you
enjoy when we're talking about Jews who
are 5
[Laughter]
I'm actually not going there at all I'm
purely Talent okay you're the the witty
the the poking the sarcasm the you have
it you have that Talent it's you can't
teach that you either have it you don't
have it you have it I appreciate it you
you really are very pull up a picture of
John Stillman well you you did there is
sort of an uncanny
yeah all right let's
Young Jon Stewart here is that a new
picture oh that's new that's a monster
can I get a young boy uh young Jones why
would they put that picture on his
Wikipedia he's gonna have better no when
he was young he was way harder no when
he was young he was way harder oh okay
I'm sorry oh there you go you have a
blonder version there's a little bit
better hair I think but yeah good hair
too okay last we got eight minutes here
wait but so you're you're not that's
Joseph could be a Jewish last name a
Syrian a serious a Syrian man like
beta is house bets David got it Ben is
son of and yes I speak I speak Arabic as
well really yeah no you're way more of a
Young Jon Stewart sounds hard to believe
Joseph Gordon hard to believe so for
example when I watch Passion to Christ
yeah I actually cannot understand what
they're saying ah literally I didn't
watch it and even if I watched it I
assure you I would not have understood
it yeah
okay so last thoughts here before we
wrap up we got seven minutes you pick
your topic what do you want to do if you
don't have a topic for you but you you
okay
what's going to happen here what are
your thoughts with yeah do you think
it's going to be ugly where are you from
the school of thought or there's going
to be a civil war it's already starting
you heard what Trump said yesterday
loyalty I'm about loyalty but so okay
give us your thoughts I do think so I
think Trump is furious there have been
reports for six seven months that
DeSantis should have said I would
consider it if Trump doesn't run and
DeSantis did has not said that and
you're supposed to say that that's the
Loyalty test I do so selfishly in two
ways I hope it's an absolute disaster
one I think it'll make it less likely
either of them win if they have a year
during which they're just going crazy at
each other and number two I think it
would be hilarious because
um honestly either one could end up on
top I know that there's this idea among
some of my colleagues that DeSantis is
similar to Trump but smarter better
spoken less Gaff prone all these things
Trump is really good with the nicknames
and the making fun of people and stuff
if DeSantis declares and they're
actually running a national campaign not
Florida but a national campaign I would
not understate the possibility of trump
really doing the DeSantis what he did to
Little Marco you know calling Ted Cruz's
wife ugly this sort of stuff it could
get ugly and it's not clear to Santa's
will get the best of it
yeah I I don't know if I disagree it's
it's a
okay so here's a question for you you're
on the inside uh strategy team for Trump
you're on the inside strategy team for
the santis yeah what are you telling
that I know but I know you're gonna say
Trump's not gonna do anything you say
anyway but what are you saying what
would you say is a strategy for if
you're like hey to win we got to do x y
z I think I I have I am terrible on
political strategy but one of the if I
if I had been advising Trump I would
have said don't announce in November
five days after a midterm election I
would I would not have done that if I'm
desantis's team I would say listen
you're not even running and in some
polls you're defeating Trump I would
wait continue to allow Trump to be
furious continue to allow Trump until he
had this low energy rally in South
Carolina nobody went he's sweating and
it was bright orange it was just
horrible keep letting Trump do this
stuff where he just looks silly and then
when you finally do announce really
think about it and do it in a way where
you actually launch a formidable
campaign instead of jumping in now and
getting involved in this stuff I
wouldn't do it
very interesting feedback okay uh
question uh uh uh do you have a book
you're promoting is there anything
you're promoting it's being written
still so I don't have it to promote so
what would you like us to drive to your
YouTube channel or Twitter love it if
people Twitter oh God no I would love it
if people went to my YouTube channel
Okay And subscribe now can we put the
link in it put the link in chat
description all of it uh and David you
have to know I can't wait to have you
the next time around I can't wait to
have a different kind of conversation
because I think the next one's going to
be better than this one because now we
kind of have an idea now we know each
other and I can come prepared we can
talk energy drinks cigars and
supplements
yesterday we're like so what are we
going to talk about tomorrow so listen
this guy's an expert on private Equity
we're going to talk Venture Capital yep
and we're talking GPT is what we're
going to talk about with them it's like
what are you talking about this guy's
not that guy said anyway well the other
David Pacman no no I'm talking about you
we were joking about it yesterday
because there is
I know there is well we must uh take him
down did you think he was first
I've been in video okay I've been
invited no in conferences and I'm like I
know you're looking for another guy I
should accept this I should have
accepted it and go on stage and say let
me tell you about your Fanboy Elon Musk
I told Pat I don't know if you're joking
right now but we're gonna spend two
hours talking about politics Trump
socialism Bernie Biden yeah and I was
proven correct yes you are by the way
shout out to Circuit City for making you
the man you are today thank you yeah no
in all seriousness I talk with my
Circuit City colleagues it threw me at
age 16 when I started 15 into a
situation where people would come in all
sorts of different types of people I
immediately have to build rapport I
immediately have to figure out how to
build a relationship get them to trust
me Etc how to talk think on my feet it
was invaluable even in what I'm doing
today it was just an unbelievable thing
and it ended sadly with as we know they
fired the top people well gang if you
enjoyed today's podcast and you want us
to bring our buddy here back give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
uh and uh share this I think the
audience wins today then when there's
banter there's disagreements there's
arguments you know you sit there you're
like I like what he said I agree with
him Pat got this wrong he got the strong
whatever you win you got the argument we
just had a conversation together we're
all winners have a great day everybody
we'll do this again on Thursday you're
all winners like he said all winners
whether you're at the bottom the top or
the middle yeah you're all winners take
care bye-bye exactly